what's going on everybody welcome to
part 12 of our data visualization with
matplotlib in Python tutorial video
series in this video what we're going to
be talking about is more customization
of various colors as well as doing some
fills so with that let's go ahead and
hop right in first of all what I want us
to go ahead and do is comment out this
section and then uncomment this section
if you don't know how to do that you
bolt you know you highlight everything
all three to comment all four to
uncomment now so at this point let's do
that and then also come up here instead
of 10d we're going to use 10 Y or
10-year also let's pick a different
company besides Tesla because Tesla
hasn't really been around for very long
let's go with eBay EBA y let's go ahead
and run that one and so here we have a
ten-year price for eBay now the first
thing I want us to go ahead and do is
instead of you know the title being
whatever let's make the title the stock
so that'll give us a little more space
to work with here we'll keep stock there
that's fine everything else can remain
the same so we'll close out of here and
the first thing I want us to go ahead
and check out is what we can do is like
here in the axes okay first of all we
colored the grid that was fine but the
next thing that we can color is like we
can do a x1 dot let's do x-axis dot
label dot set underscore color and we
can change the color of these labels so
we can do that with the x-axis we're
changing that to Siam then we can do
that as well to the y-axis and we can
change that to red or something so we
can save and run that and so now you can
see that label right date is now cyan
and price is red okay so there's a quick
example the next thing that we can do is
like let's look again at the chart and
we can see that you know we've got
basically the prices here for
eBay I make a lot of sense that's pretty
funny that averages out to 10 20 30 40
50 60 70 eva is quite the volatile stock
anyway
let's say we actually like only wanted
very specific numbers the way that we
can do that is we can say a x1 dot set
underscore y ticks and we can set those
ticks as let's say 0 25 50 and 75 okay
let's say we want to set the tick
markers as that so we can save and run
that and we're able to do that right so
0 25 50 and 75 so if you want something
very specific you can make those marks
now the next thing I want us to go ahead
and cover is going to be Phil's
so with Phil's what we can do is we can
fill something now right now we're
feeling like we're plotting let's say
price so what if we did instead of
plotting price let's comment that out
and let's actually do a x1 dot fill
underscore between and we want to fill
between what we date close P and then a
basically a price right so date close P
and like 0 okay so we'll fill between
there and we're going to get an error
about the legend because we don't have a
label so just keep that in mind it's
coming okay so now we've got this fill
and we start at 0 and what it's done is
it's basically filled between 0 and the
price so some people like to visualize
stock price this way rather than just a
simple line now of course we can do kind
of the same thing we've done in the past
and we could just go ahead and let that
line plot and then we would also get our
legend okay so we could do something
like that and it's totally fine now the
next thing that we can do with fills is
a lot of times people add like a slight
alpha to fill because fill will fill so
if there was something else there we
would cover it but if we add some or we
take away from alpha what we're able to
do is because alphas a degree of Oh peg
miss what we can do is still see
whatever was there so what we can say
here is
alpha equals 0.3 let's say okay so there
we go we've got the line and if we we
wouldn't see this solid blue line if we
weren't plotting that solid blue line
just for the record we just happen to be
plotting that right now
so one another thing that we could do is
for example so we've got this price here
what if we wanted to maybe instead of
doing this fill like let's get rid of
this fill and like maybe maybe we bought
this stock let's say we bought this
stock at twenty five dollars okay so we
bought eBay at twenty five dollars
an example might be or actually let's
let me restart this real quick let's see
where's the starting price yeah okay so
let's go with the start price here as
like we'll say we actually started
buying into eBay at thirty six dollars
okay so that way it'll kind of make
sense on the chart anyway so let's say
we start at thirty six dollars
what we're going to do is we'll keep
plotting date and instead of doing fill
between like this an interesting thing
that we can do is we can say fill
between instead let's say instead of
closed P we could say thirty six what if
we did something like that we'll leave
the other plot actually so let's run
that real quick and now you can see that
it always felt it always fills based on
the 36 number right so we invested here
let's profit this is loss right and then
this is profit well an interesting thing
that we can continue doing is we can
actually fill based on a little bit of
logic so here we're saying date closed P
and actually what we could do is we
could say between closed p and then
closed p of 0 so this would be the first
price that we have on file for that
company so we could run that one more
time hopefully and that should be the
same thing right so now we could plot
any company in assuming we invest in
that company at it's like IPO we're good
to go so we could plot say
Twitter okay let's say and that would be
an example of Twitter's you know price
and our profit or loss with Twitter now
moving back to eBay though that's really
what I'm interested in doing will do
eBay and then we'll fill between these
numbers but then we can add logic so
we've got alpha equals 0.3 what we can
do is before alpha or really after we
can add another keyword argument here
and that keyword argument will be where
without the caps so where is equal to
and then we're gonna say we're close P
is greater than the close p0 that should
work we'll see what happens okay so
let's run that real quick okay so every
time the price was greater than that
36 ish dollar value it's filling it so
what if okay so we're investing so let's
say we actually want to make give it a
color so we're going to say face color
it has a face basically that's what
happens with polygons and then also
polygons have an edge color but we're
not really gonna worry about that for
now we'll just give it a face color so
that should be good
so that would be you know gain right
green would be gain and then below green
would be lost so we would maybe make
that red so let's add main point five
alpha let's take this exact line copy it
paste it and then we're going to sted
where clothes is less than that starting
point value we make it red okay so now
we can save and run that and then we
have a chart like this right so this is
our loss so these are sad days for us
and then these are happy days for us
okay so we can do that or again we can
use Twitter as another example right so
the gains loss gains loss okay so
there's an example of just a few of the
customization options that we can do
with like fill between and then
also we colored some other stuff but
mostly I just wanted to show the fill
between but again the fill between it's
hard because it doesn't you can't have a
label with it so if you really wanted a
label you know you would have to you
know maybe you would do something like
this like a X 1 X 1 dot plot and then
nothing nothing line width equals 5
label equals loss and then color equals
whoops red right and then you could come
through here paste green gain and then
now we'll add let's add that alpha 2 so
alpha equals 0.5 alpha equals whoops
alpha equals 0.5 something like that
and now we've got you know price loss
would be the red and gain is the green
fill and all that so anyways there's
like an example how you can use fills
for all kinds of stuff will actually
come back to fills again and a little
bit doing an even more dynamic fill than
this but that'll do for now so anyways
hopefully you enjoy it if you have any
questions or comments up to this point
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time